Greetings, everyone.
We're going to get started.
So we've now arrived.
You've had the chance to
unpack the plenary in a cohort
or in the context
of your choice.
Now we're going to get to work.
So roll up those sleeves
and get ready to engage
in an implementation
workshop, we're calling them.
So throughout the planning
of this conference,
we've been thinking
a lot about what
do we really mean by the phrase
"the science of learning."
And you heard Erin speak to
that at a fairly general level.
We'd like to have you pull out
of your registration folders
the chart that she
briefly referenced.
This is going to be key
for our session today.
With this horizontally
oriented sheet.
The game plan for
our session today
is to let you think about
a problem of practice,
a challenge that you're
facing in the teaching you're
doing directly, or in
the teaching being done
and the learning being done
by the courses and faculty
that you support.
After you think
about that challenge,
momentarily we're going to ask
you to identify one of these--
one of a subset
of five principles
that we've chosen to then think
more about, and to make some
plans.
So indeed, in the spirit
of it being a workshop,
there will be a
lot of time for you
to be fleshing out
trajectories that will
be useful in your own context.
And then at the end, we'll share
back out to the larger group.
To get us started,
though, let's take
a minute to look
at the sheet itself
since we didn't have a lot of
time for that in the opening.
And think about
these nine principles
that are roughly
bucketed into cognitive
behavioral and affective,
with two as bookends,
thinking about aiming by
which we engage what Steve
Kosslyn was talking about, and
being really clear about what
is it that we want our students
to know and do as a result
of the learning experience.
Detect and scaffold,
be building on what
it is the students already know
in ways that sequence for them.
To model activating guide,
and you can see throughout,
to the right in the columns,
some more concrete ways
to enact these
kinds of principles.
On the affective
dimensions, to connect
and to have high expectations,
and then to make sense of it
all in assessing.
What we've done is
put together examples,
concrete manifestations
or practices,
that build on and expand beyond
what's in the rightmost column.
So you'll see here
a couple of examples
to help you visualize well, what
do we really mean by activate?
What could that look
like in my classroom?
You'll be given the chance
to look at more such examples
and think of additional
ones for your own.
And as I said, make a
plan for your context.
Because we knew that we
wouldn't be able to do justice
to all nine
principles, we decided
that we would focus us
all today on these five.
So again, in a moment
you'll be given a chance
to think about a
problem of practice
and to then connect
with one of these.
I want to say, now that
you have the big picture,
I want to say a
special thank you,
an introduction to my
wonderful colleagues.
Adrienne Phelps-Coco, who is
at the Division of Continuing
Education, and
Josh Bookin, who's
at the Graduate
School of Education.
When I decided that
I wanted to have
this be one of our
implementation workshops,
I picked up the bat phone and
called my fantastic colleagues
who I knew would be
incredibly expert and skilled
and lovely to work with.
And that's been
absolutely the case.
So thanks to you
both for what we're
about to experience today.
Any questions about
what we're up to here?
OK.
I'm going to hand
it over to Adrienne.
Hello.
Welcome, everybody.
So what we want to
do is make sure,
as we think about the
science of learning,
that it fits in with your
course, and with the practices
that you're doing, and with the
challenges that you're facing.
We're hoping that this
session can help you come up
with some solutions to actual
challenges that you have,
or if you are someone who
works with faculty in designing
their courses, to
actual challenges
that you often hear
people encounter.
So what we want to
do today, is we're
going to walk you
through a series of steps
to think about some
of those challenges,
and then to brainstorm some
solutions with your colleagues.
So to get started, there is a--
in the center of
your table, there
is a worksheet that
has a paper clip.
Not the thing that's
in the envelope.
The thing that's sitting open on
the table with the paper clip.
The envelope will
come in a minute.
So if you can distribute
those amongst yourselves,
that'll be our step one here.
Is this the worksheet?
Yes.
All right.
Everybody got it?
So what we want to do is start
with the very first step, where
we want to think about
a problem of practice.
And what we mean
by that is either
a challenge that you
know you're facing,
or something that crops
up in your evaluations,
you're not quite sure
what to make of it.
Again, if you're
working with faculty,
something that you hear
from people that you would
like to have some solutions for.
So we want you to take
about five minutes,
and just write about this
challenge for yourself.
Finish early, you can talk
with the person next to you.
But let's define the problem.
Then we'll start
getting into solutions.
So you can probably
guess what we're
about to do next, which
is, our goal here is really
to think about how we can use
the science of learning to make
improvements to your course
or the courses you're working
with, with these challenges.
So what we want you
to do is sort of
read over those categories
just a little bit again,
and see if you get
a sense of which
of these might be most helpful
for solving your challenge.
And then what we're
going to do is
we're all going to stand up
and move to tables so you
can discuss your challenges.
But take just a second,
look over these principles.
All right.
So here's what I'm going to do.
I'm going to ask
for a show of hands
for who is interested
in which principle,
and that way we're going to
divide up the tables in a way
that, you know, if half of
you want to talk about detect,
we'll make a lot of detect
tables, and if only a few
of you want to talk about
activate, we'll just make one.
Sound good?
All right.
[LAUGHS] You guys, make it two.
Make it two.
All right.
That's good.
Good to know.
So while they're figuring
out the tables here,
I want to tell you a little bit
about what we're going to do.
Is once we have the tables,
we'll put all the numbers up.
You can go to the table for the
principle you're interested in.
And then there is a packet
at the middle of the table.
And inside that
packet, you're going
to find a whole lot more
information about each
of these principles,
including examples
that are being used here
at Harvard and elsewhere,
and also just a little bit
more examples of how you
might put this into practice.
And what we're going
to ask you to do
is spend some time reading
over the part of your packet
that applies to your table.
So we gave you all
the whole packet
so you can come away
with the whole thing.
But if you're in activate,
you can skip straight
to the activate.
And think about
those ideas, and then
to think about how
you might adapt them
for your own classroom
practice, and then we're
going to do some group share
out and some collective
note-taking, so that we can
come away with as many ideas
as we possibly can.
That sound good to everybody?
All right.
Anybody have any questions about
any of these up to this point?
All right, everyone.
So as you get settled, do what
many of you are already doing.
Please introduce yourself to
the other people at the table.
If you have a lot of
people at your table,
you may want to
split into two groups
so you have smaller groups
talking to each other.
But just do a
quick introduction,
tell people why you're here,
what your problem of practice
is.
We're only going to spend
about five minutes on this,
so let's make it more
of a lightning round.
But take a minute to
introduce yourselves.
All right, everyone.
Looks like intros are winding
down at some of the tables,
so I want to tell you
what's going next.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
Now is the time to open up
that packet if you have not
and find your principle.
And we want you to
spend the next eight
minutes or so thinking about--
reading through the
ideas for your principle.
And then looking at parts
C and D on your worksheet.
And just really
thinking about, as you
read the examples of the
handout, do any of them
seem like they're going
to work for your context,
or might they work
if you adapted them?
And then also, are there
any other practices
that you're already doing?
Or that learning
about these principles
make you think that, that
could then be useful?
So you want to spend about eight
minutes doing some writing,
thinking on your own.
If you need to finish interests
first, that's totally fine.
All right, everybody.
Seems like the conversation
has picked back up again,
which is a good thing.
So even if you're not completely
done with your writing,
you can always go
back to that later on.
But what we want to do here
is you'll see in this packet,
we have given you some
examples that we have gathered
of either examples from Harvard,
or from elsewhere, that we
really think are
thought-provoking and can
help everyone improve
their teaching.
But what we'd really like
to do is expand on that.
So for the next 15 minutes,
what we want you to do
is share with each
other any ideas
that you came up with,
or collectively work
on some ideas.
And we have a series
of Google Docs
for each of these principles.
So these are the URLs for
each of the Google Docs.
And we're going to ask
one person from each group
to be the note taker.
And we will share all
of this out later on.
But our goal here
is to really expand
on what you've
got in this packet
and create a greater
bank of ideas
that everyone can draw from.
Sound good?
Or even to just
talk about how you
might use one of
the things that's
in the packet in
your own context.
Absolutely.
Doesn't have to be a huge leap.
15 minutes.
OK.
Thank you for engaging
deeply with the material
and with each other.
I sat in on a variety
of conversations
and found rich
problems of practice
that people were workshopping
in really interesting ways.
What we'd like to
do now is to get
a little bit of
a snippet of what
happened at the
various tables and
with the various principles.
This is not going
to be the only time
that you're going to be able
to interact with other people's
topics.
So there's the Google Docs that
people are taking notes in,
and some groups are
taking notes by hand.
Feel free to continue to do
that throughout the remainder
of the session.
We'll collect those and
we'll send those links out
to everyone.
The rest of the
packet, obviously,
with the other four
principles that you probably
haven't had a
chance to read yet,
but hopefully are
good resources,
will also be available.
But what we're doing now is
we have three minutes, pretty
quick share outs per principle.
And so I will try
to keep us to that.
But we'd love to hear
interesting ideas,
unresolved issues, or insights
that your group came up with.
So we'll start with aim.
So these first two tables.
So if anyone wants to volunteer.
All right.
Hi, everybody.
My name is Jeremy.
I had the pleasure of working
with Jascha, Ramona, and Laura
on aim.
We did not resolve all
of the issues with regard
to linking our teaching goals to
learners' learning objectives.
We did sort of
unanimously decide,
or come to a consensus,
that being very explicit,
being very upfront about
what our specific teaching
goals were early in the teaching
encounter, or in a curriculum,
and then doing some sort
of detection or assessment
to determine how those goals
align with learners' objectives
is important.
Particularly in this
contemporary era in which we
are judged by
student evaluations
and their perceptions of
the utility of the courses
and content that we develop.
Along those lines, we
struggled with the challenge
of the sort of one room
schoolhouse model, where
we may have learners with
different levels of knowledge,
with different perspectives,
with different agendas
coming into a teaching encounter
or into a course of curriculum.
And we did not, kind
of, fully address
how to tackle that challenge.
Similarly, we
struggled with the idea
of developing goals or
end-learning objectives that
are more content
or factual based,
and maybe less about analysis
and application and higher
level skills, and how to
build those in a way that
can be meaningful
for the learners
and that can be assessed in a
meaningful way down the road.
Did I miss anything?
I don't think so.
That was excellent.
Nicely done.
And a great model.
Anything that this group
would like to add about,
sort of, aim.
Ideas can be specific.
Things people wanted to
try, or general principles.
Sure.
So I'm Holly from
the second aim table,
and I'll just read a
couple from our group.
We have a number of
people who support faculty
in the creating of
learning objectives,
and assessment of learning.
And so we had some really
interesting conversations
about how to do that
because faculty will often
think that everything
they're teaching is critical.
So how do you help them
to identify the enduring
understandings?
And sometimes having
an outside perspective
either from an
educational specialist,
or convening a group of
alums from a course that
are five years out,
that you might actually
run into an airport,
are two practical ways
that we talked about to try
to crystallize those enduring
understandings.
We were all really taken by
that part of the aim idea.
We talked about posting
learning objectives
in the physical
classroom environment,
and/or in some electronic
way checking in with students
every one to two weeks to
say, like, how far along
are we progressing?
I know that's getting
a little bit into some
of the more assessing
things, but just making sure
that you're continuously
revisiting the learning
objectives as opposed to
writing them and putting them
aside, or putting them
on your first slide
and putting them aside.
Wonderful.
One thing I'm struck by about
aim is how ambitious, sort of,
the airport goal is, and
that less can often be more
of this idea of everything
seems important,
but then nothing gets sort of
the treatment that it deserves.
And I think these schematics are
very interesting to think, sort
of how much are we trying
to do, and how much they
relate to each other.
So even if we don't
give them to students,
how do we ourselves understand
how these things all
fit together?
Great.
Thank you.
What's next?
Yeah.
Next table for detect.
Hi, I'm Margaret,
and our group talked
about the detect principle,
finding appropriate ways
to gauge what your students
know and don't know.
And our group had
people who play
a number of different roles in
a number of different schools.
So that was really
great, and I'm
hoping that my
peers will speak in
if I forget anything because
I was busily taking notes.
One theme that came
up with our group
is the importance of building
trust in your community,
and making sure that
the students know
that it's OK to ask questions.
And also we discuss how
it's great to empower
the students to decide
themselves how are
we going to build a community.
And that will help with detect.
Another topic that
we talked about was
the power of small group
discussions and presentations
and how that peer effect can
be motivating to help students
prepare and do the
reading, or whatever work
is needed before class.
And if they don't do the
work or reading, that one,
they need to be able to own it
and acknowledge it when they're
doing small group
work, and secondly,
that they may be motivated to
do that work because they know
that their peers are depending
on them to contribute
to that small group work.
We also talked
about cases in which
students need to
self-evaluate their own work.
And it was related
that students are often
very highly critical of
themselves, and maybe
one of that, this was
in the case of speaking,
that the students
may be self-critical
because they don't realize
the huge amount of effort that
goes into preparing
presentations or speeches.
And it would be great to
be transparent about that
so that they know how much
time it takes and then we'd
have a better gauge about
how to self-evaluate where
they are currently
in their skills
and how they can improve.
We also talked
about the new course
schedules and what do you do if
you have a three hour stretch
of time to cover things.
I'm not sure we
solved that problem,
but if anyone has any ideas,
please go to the Google Doc.
And finally, we also touched
on the in-class polling.
What do you do with the faculty
with whom you work, you know,
are not really on
board on using that?
What are some possible
other ways to address that?
And we didn't really solve
that challenge quite either,
but again, please,
go to the Google Doc
and write your ideas.
Great.
Thank you.
And the other group from detect?
Things to add?
Or was that the one--
that was one group.
OK.
So I think one thing
I'll say about detect
that-- a middle point you made
about, sort of, meta-cognition,
or self-assessment, I think that
is very powerful as a modality,
and the learning sciences
says that as well.
And I like how you
also talk about,
in some ways modeling for them
that meta-cognition, and giving
them a sense of how hard it
is to do a public speech,
and sort of, what are the
component parts before they
then overly critically assess
themselves against, sort of,
unfair metrics.
So activate, from this table.
Anyone want to share some
thoughts, or willing to?
So ours is going
to be really broad.
Basically, we each had
struggles that other schools
had conquered.
So I think just the
takeaway for this
is to look and see what
other schools are doing.
So for example, my challenge
was looking at large lectures
at 8:00 AM for working
adults, and they're taped.
So students don't come.
What do you do?
And this is what spurred the
medical school's curriculum
reform.
Business schools looking
at how to bring more voices
into their case discussions,
and that's something
that the Kennedy School is
looking at with Teachly.
So we just found that
if we're looking around
at other schools, people
are doing things and having
the same challenges that
we're having and solving them.
Great.
Thank you.
Table six.
Thoughts to add in
terms of activate?
Well, we talked about one
particular problem, probably
mostly was dealing
with the consultancy.
A problem where
we had a classroom
of doctors and nurses
learning to teach
and some of the problems
that come up with in terms
of hierarchies, getting
people to work together
and not clump together.
And talked mostly
about consultancies
and how those might be in--
kind of what we're
doing here, and how
that might help them solve
some of those problems.
I don't know if you
wanted to add anything.
I also discovered the problem
that I had written down
would probably better
addressed stepping back
a little bit, which is also a
good thing to realize, right?
That's great.
Yeah.
Were you going to say
what your problem was?
What your challenge was?
It's mostly dealing with a
faculty member who is ambitious
and not being able
to rein in some
of the excitedness of his plans.
And just having that person then
go on and do other things, kind
of, just not feeling very
useful in that moment,
and trying to come up
with a solution when maybe
it really should've started in a
negotiation back at that level.
Great.
Thank you.
Yeah.
And then the last
table on activate.
We had a lot of
different ideas as we
were talking about
different challenges,
but one of the themes
that we talked about
was creating self-driven
activities or expectations
or norms on the
part of the people
learning in our different
situations, where
they're actually
setting their own goals,
or working towards that.
And then we just help them
negotiate that with each other.
We were also talking about
finding opportunities
for more collaborative
activities where they can learn
from each other,
rather than having
us stand in as an instructor.
Really finding
opportunities for them
to practice their
learning through showing.
And we also talked about
finding opportunities
for those students
to frame content,
or like create the content
that they want to learn.
And if that doesn't work,
finding opportunities for them
to reflect or personalize
their approach
to the content in a way that's
useful and applicable to them
so that they know what
they're taking away
while they're actually in
the learning situation.
Great.
Thank you.
One of the things I hear
coming through that theme
that your table
was talking about
is motivation and self-efficacy.
And another thing that, in
terms of peer instruction
and learning from
each other, I was
struck that one of the
most dramatic finding
of the research literature is
that when students are teaching
each other, the person
doing the teaching
tends to learn more than the
student getting instructed.
So I had always assumed it
would be the other way around.
So it can be very powerful
in all directions.
Great.
So the connect table.
So we talked about the
challenge of connecting,
and we had some really
interesting examples,
particularly in online
or very large courses,
or folks who are doing part-time
learning where you can never
gauge who's in the room
or why they're there.
So we had a lot of discussions
about different techniques
to try.
And something
interesting is to make
them feel a connection to
you as the instructor, which
is a kind of strange thing
maybe in an online setting
to feel like you
can take the time
to try to get the
students to know you
and to understand that you're
not there just to make this
difficult for them, but that
you are motivated to help them.
So we talked about that.
We talked about some
challenges in connecting
in courses that are actually
really hard because sometimes
they'll think that you're just
in it to embarrass them or give
them a terrible
grade or something.
And we talked about
the importance
of sort of setting
that vision upfront,
even taking the time,
especially in the beginning,
to make that connection
to their bigger picture.
Why are they there?
What-- this is going
to be a long journey,
but go on it with me.
And then trying to reiterate
that message a few times
throughout the semester.
And then a great
tip at the very end
of the semester, once
hopefully they've
done that journey with you,
to ask if they could offer
words of advice or wisdom.
What did they wish they knew
at the beginning of the course?
And then having that available
in your pocket for when
you teach it the next
time because it's
coming from other students,
not from scary you.
And then we just
talked in general
about the concept of fostering
participation and engagement,
which we felt is really
important to connection.
And again, that's
establishing what
I know in the business school
we call a learning contract
upfront, just letting them
know that what you expect
preparation being
very essential,
as is participation, and that
the more that they do that,
the more they'll get out of it.
And trying as best you can
to create a safe environment,
just to make sure that people
feel comfortable speaking up.
That's what we talked about.
Great.
I love that one of the many
ideas you said in there
is the idea of connecting
even between classes
of different years.
So there's connections
that can go
in so many different
directions, but even
that longitudinal,
institutional knowledge.
That's a great idea.
So the last principle, assess.
And this is assessing
our own teaching,
not assessing the
student's learning.
But so anyone who'd be
comfortable sharing out?
I don't know that we did such a
good job tackling the assessing
because we ended up touching
on all these other issues, too,
but all because
of the challenges
of figuring out how to assess.
And so we didn't come
up with solutions.
We had a couple of
ideas which were having
in-class polling that
can be showing live,
so you get a sense of,
basically, is this working?
And identifying problems
before moving on past them.
We talked about not being
too adherent to student
evaluations, but having--
going back to the
aims, which is like,
this all kind of
comes full circle.
But going back to the
aims and thinking,
you know, how can we
figure out five years out
whether they know it or not?
And is there a way
we can implement
that to reach out to people
and find out what they know?
And then finally, we talked
about the value of small groups
within the class with guided
questions as a way of you
can figure out what
they knew coming in,
and they can teach each other
within that small group,
and that also empowers them
to speak up within the class.
So I think those are the
main things that we covered.
Yeah.
But what we all agreed on is
that there is not a good way
to assess as far as
we can tell right now.
And if you guys
have other thoughts,
that would be really
helpful to everyone.
That's great.
Let's see.
In terms of other
thoughts on assess.
I mean, I am struck
by the last point
you made of, sort
of, if we're trying
to assess the efficacy
of our teaching,
assessing our
students' learning.
If you actually get
them in groups and see,
can they do the tasks that
we're asking them to do?
That is really good
real time feedback.
In addition to a
polling of, you know,
does this make sense to you?
Or actually can you
do this question?
But I mean, one thing I've seen,
and I'll circle back to this
and see if my colleagues
have other thoughts,
but I'm hearing in a
really good productive way
the difficulty of
isolating these principles
from each other.
In the same way,
one of the things
that I have found
most powerful for me
as I think about how to
tackle teaching problems,
is the idea of having a
pedagogical repertoire,
and then matching it
to the right situation.
And in this case,
we're almost meta here.
It's sort of we have a
teaching problem, a practice,
and we're trying to
figure out what principle
can be sort of the
entry point, or, sort
of, the main lever for change.
But they're all interconnected,
and so when we hear
about people starting with--
being in activate
and realizing they
want to go back
towards aim, or people
who are doing things about
detect and seeing that trust
and connecting is a
really important way
to be able to detect because
people aren't going to give you
the data that you need if
they don't feel comfortable.
And so I feel like my last
thought on the assess question
that you opened up
was it is a thing
to start from the beginning as
a culture in the classroom, of I
myself am very open to learning
from you and making changes,
so it's the in-class polling,
it's the one-minute papers
at the end of the
first class session,
it's the mid-semester feedback,
it's reporting it back to them
and then showing that
you're doing those changes.
Such that-- because I
often read course evals
and help faculty
members digest them,
and it's not surprising,
but notable to me
how many times students
say, this was an issue.
The faculty got data from
us and really addressed it,
and I deeply
appreciate that, and we
saw how it changed over the
trajectory of the experience.
So that sort of building
assessment in on a daily basis
has, to me, been
really powerful.
I don't know if you
have anything to add
on that before we transition.
I think if I can
just add one thing.
So I've been using anonymous
feedback surveys built
into Canvas, which are
basically a variation
on the minute paper.
And I've been doing it for
four years now, I think.
And I will never
teach without it
again because you learn so much.
You think you can
assess how people
are doing by looking
them in the eye,
but when you actually ask
them, you learn things like,
oh, this activity didn't go
well because it was too hard,
or because all of my
kids have the flu,
and it was just a hard week.
You get all of this
information from people
that you wouldn't otherwise
get just by asking,
and it's wonderful.
So I highly, highly
recommend it.
Yeah?
So I just-- we tried that
last year, and what we found
was that all we did was invite
the angry people to anonymously
tear us apart.
And then people
started skipping it.
And I actually ended up having
students come up after and say,
I'm not one of them.
I'm on your side.
And so we decided not
to do it this year.
So, you know, I think
they can go both ways.
It can.
I make them worth
one point every week.
I mean, that's silly, but
it does get people to do it.
And I also-- I report back
on it every single week.
So I say, this many people--
half the group thought this
activity was fantastic,
the other half did not.
And that reporting lets them
see that there are lots of sides
to every issue, so that if--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
You obviously don't make
people as angry as we do.
We have a response here.
The other thing that we
do to get around this,
like, just hearing
the complaints issue,
is that we have them as
Plus Deltas, which I think
is in one of these as well.
And so they have
to say one thing
that they want to see more
of because it's going well
for them, and one thing
they want to change.
Which can come still
across as a complaint,
but also it can come
as a more productive,
constructive thought.
Great.
Wow.
So we are--
Am I on?
Yes, I'm on.
OK.
We're close to the end
of our time together.
I'd like you to think about
the problem of practice
that you wrote about
when we started.
Think about what
it is that you've
learned in discussion
with others today,
in reading the handouts, in
hearing from other groups.
And the last prompt on the
worksheet is just to think,
what is one thing you are going
to try out or do differently
or even think more about as a
result of this conversation?
So take a moment
and jot that down,
and we'll hear from a few of
you about your own trajectory
during this session.
All right.
Sorry.
So a couple of takeaways
that we hope you leave with.
The first is the generosity and
richness of the contributions
that you've made with each
other to the Google Docs,
and in the report- out.
There's only so
much that can happen
in a 75-minute chunk of
time, but a lot has happened.
We want to continue to use the
Google Docs as a repository
for great ideas.
So if you took notes and
didn't use a Google Doc,
please leave your sheet
and we'll upload it.
I also was struck in the plenary
by Steve Kosslyn's comment
about the distinction
between knowing
the skill or the content and
knowing when and how to use it.
And I think we've seen both
the potential for transfer
across context of some
of these practices,
and also some of the
challenges for that.
At the bottom of the
handout, you've seen--
we've listed
additional resources.
Some of these are just places
where we ourselves generated
or found these exercises.
So we encourage you to
check these out as well.
What are a couple
of takeaways, or I
plan to do this
differently or better
as a result of the session
that you wrote about?
What's something that--
Yes.
Casey.
I'm going to try at
the end of unit one
doing a Plus Delta
just on an index card.
So asking students, you know,
so we're a third of the way
through the semester now, what
do you want to see more of?
And what suggestions do you have
for things you want to change?
That's great.
And that's in an online context.
So I think I'm actually going
to do it in-class on index cards
and ask them to drop them into
a box as they walk out the door.
Great.
OK.
Others?
I think we might find ways
to reincorporate the surveys
because I like the idea
of reporting back to them
so they-- because I think
that our problem was that they
didn't take it seriously.
And so I think that
really showing them
that we're listening
to them, I think
that that's incredibly helpful.
Other things.
Virginia, what are you
going to do differently?
Mine was the same, actually.
Well, I was getting some
anonymous feedback each week
on Canvas.
Because I think it's also a
way to report back and help
shape their expectations
and keep them realistic.
And mine as well.
I think just using the map
of the general understanding,
the airport concept, what
do we want them to learn,
and then what do we
want them to remember,
both in terms of when
I work with faculty
and thinking about
the course overall,
or the session, but also
in terms of my own work.
I spend a lot of time
developing cases and using
that construct to help me
think about the case material
and how I'm going
to put it together.
Great.
Thank you so much.
Well, in trying to
walk our own talk,
you'll be receiving,
for the conference
overall, a quick survey.
And there will be
a space for you
to share feedback
about this session
because this was a
new experience for us.
And we plan to read--
and repurpose in different ways.
We'd love to hear what worked
and what didn't for you.
And we look forward
to continuing
to be in touch
virtually and in person.
So thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]